Great Wings beating still above the
staggering girl,
her thighs,
caressed by the dark webs her nape,
caught in his bill.
He holds her helpless breast upon his
breast.
How can those terrified vague fingers
push the feathered glory from her
loosening thighs and how can body lead
in that white rush but feel the strange
heart beating where it lies,
a shutter in the loins in genders there,
the broken wall,
the burning roof and tower and agamemnon
dead being so caught up,
so mastered by the brute blood of the
air.
Did she put on his knowledge with his
power before the indifferent beak could
let her drop later,
and the Swan is a sonnet that William
Butler yeats wrote and rewrote many
times,
but finally appeared in this form in his
renowned collection called the tower
published in 1928 when he was 63.
The Tower was the first book of poems he
released after becoming a Nobel laureate
five years prior.
Gates is of that exceptionally rare
breed of artists who improved in quality
as he entered his late life.
The poem takes it subject from Greek
mythology.
The story of Zeus,
assuming the form of a swan to seduce
later wife of the Spartan King
[inaudible] who bore from this union,
Helen of troy,
whose infidelity ignited the Trojan war
and the beginning of classical history.
Now,
before we explore the way yates used the
subject to create meaning,
just take a quick look at the actual
shape of the poem.
There's something unsettling about it.
The form of the sonnet appears to be
hijacked everywhere.
It's twisted and torn apart like Dr.
Frankenstein Yates has surgically
attached the Shakespearean Sonnet with
its first two quatrains,
featuring an a,
a,
b,
a b rhyme scheme with the Petrarchan
sonnet in the last six lines and an efg
efg rhyme scheme,
including the unnerving slant,
Ryan up and drop,
which robs the final moment of any
auditory closure,
most notable of although his line 11,
which appears to be slashed and split
into leaving the final three lines,
just dangling there like late to herself
in the indifferent beak of the Swan.
In this way,
yates commits a kind of violence on the
sonnet form,
not for nothing.
The poet is attempting to augment the
violent content of his work,
his sonnets,
at least she experienced on it's are
traditionally about great love,
and yet here yates uses the form to
describe what could be considered the
exact opposite,
an act of violent rape,
and if you look at successive versions
of later and the Swan,
you can see that yates turned up the
volume on this violence.
For example,
in one version,
the poem begins,
a rush a sudden we'll and hovering
still,
the bird descends,
her frail thighs pressed by the webbed
toes,
and that all powerful bill has laid her
helpless face upon his breast.
Now,
the early version almost assumes late as
acquiescence to the gods advances in the
later version beginning with the shock
of a sudden blow.
Zeus is molestation,
is intensely emphasize and emphasize too
is later and the readers disorientation
the great wings beating still the
ambiguity of beating still.
How can wings be still if they're
beating?
And on the other hand,
if he means that they're still beating,
that means terrifyingly,
that the rape has already begun while
the swan is still in the air.
Now in this version,
the girl is staggering,
her thighs caressed a word that disturbs
us by comingling,
the erotic with the vicious something
that Yates does,
a bunch of this poem caressed by the
dark webs that gives a sense of just how
big the bird is because not even the
toes,
but the webs between the toes are what's
caressing her and it should be noted
that both the first and second line and
with anjem myths pulling us awkwardly
through the verse,
and it's not until the last line of that
first that we finally get the subject.
He as if everything was happening so
fast that later couldn't find her
bearings until the gruesome act was
already underway.
The first quatrain of later and the swan
is disturbing in the extreme,
setting the scene from latest,
horrified point of view.
Then we have the second quadrant,
which is made up of two rhetorical
questions,
both seem to ask the same thing.
What could lay to do against the awesome
power of a God?
How could she possibly resist?
How can she do anything but feel the
strange heart beating where it lies?
These questions can be read in two ways.
You can read them rhetorically,
which is to say read them as saying,
obviously she can't do anything and such
as the tragedy of the poem,
but I think Yates invites us to read
them literally as well,
which is to say what can she do more on
that in a moment after the first two
verses comes the Volta,
a term for when a sonnet turns and the
questions or events posed in the first
lines are answered in this case,
after the shutter,
referring both to the moment of
ejaculation and latest fear.
We have the poet examining the
consequences of the rate and they are
really far reaching the broken wall,
the burning roof and tower,
all intimate that the rape of late at
not only caused but insured the eventual
destruction of troy and the rise of
Greece and western history,
a history that was born out of rape,
war and murder,
and agamemnon dead.
Here we have gates own alteration to the
mythological history as the story goes,
later,
laid two eggs,
one bore helen and pollux Demi Gods and
children of Zeus and the other bore
caster and Clayton Nestra,
children of latest mortal husband Tim
Darrius,
who she laid with the same night by
citing the death of Agamemnon,
famously killed by his wife,
Clytemnestra,
as among the faded ramifications of the
rape.
Yates demonstrates the full effect of
the trauma and by doing this he reaches
into the history of art as well because
the calls to troy and agamemnon staff
bring to mind respectively.
Homer's Iliad,
the pinnacle of the epic form and
escalates his play,
the Oresteia,
the first great work of Western drama.
All this is done in 11 words without
even mentioning the continued sexual
overtones.
And then Yates concludes the poem with
one final question.
Did she put on his knowledge with his
power before at the indifferent beak
could let her drop and to understand
this and the poem itself and its larger
context,
we have to know a little bit more about
yates and his way of thinking from his
early life.
Yates had always been drawn to
mysticism,
to astrology and to the occult in Middle
Age,
he developed his own complex
metaphysical and cosmic system,
which he laid out in extreme detail in a
book called a vision.
One of the key ideas was that history
was made up into gyres or cycles of
about 2000 years,
alternating between ages of spirituality
and ages of secularism.
Each cycle reached the peak of its
excellence in the exact middle than
decades,
slowly until it was finally replaced by
the new one.
This idea was explored most potently in
his famous poem.
The second coming,
Yates identified his own time,
our time as the end of the religious
cycle of Christianity,
and envision the start of a new unknown
cycle of secularism initiated by the
coming of a great beast.
The last time such a cycle began is the
subject of later and the Swan,
the rape of later by Zeus signals the
start of the classical era around 2000
BC.
In each case,
the divine visits,
the earth and leaves the seeds of the
history that is to come.
This is the key to this question.
Did she put on his knowledge with his
power,
did later glimpse the future.
She was creating the cycle.
She was inaugurating before the
indifferent.
God flew away in some way.
He suggests the shape of things to come
is contained in its origin,
but can humans discern it?
That's the question.
Now,
all this stuff about gyres and cycles
and mystical systems,
it's pretty out there.
Clearly it isn't in any way scientific
or even very specific.
There's a real debate about whether
Yates believed any of it probably in
some way he did,
but what was clearly more important to
him was having a unified system in the
first place because it was from the many
symbols of this unity that Yates was
able to extract his strongest poetry.
Having that Matrix of sliding meanings
to work with so tightly,
intricately woven meant that pulling one
string,
evoking one symbol,
laying one idea into the form and meter
of a sonnet would make the rest of the
web light up like a Christmas tree,
signifying a complexity that invites the
reader into a number of simultaneous
interpretations.
By situating the poem at a fulcrum in
history equal to our own,
we're forced to look both at what we're
coming out of and what we're heading
toward.
A relevant question for any age,
particularly relevant for Yates's own.
When the trauma of World War One must
have come like a sudden blow by,
posing questions if possible,
resistance to this brutal act,
but showing no resistance on the part of
later even possible enjoyment.
The readers themselves are called on to
imagine how we resist oppression and the
nature of resistance itself,
both from a feminist point of view and a
political one by depicting an encounter
with the divine,
so savagely we're asked to examine the
price of inspiration and by posing
questions without giving answers.
The knowledge and the power of poetry
itself is called into question.
All these things are compressed into
Yates's later and the swan spring loaded
triggered by an image or a tense or upon
or a slant.
Ryan,
that's so much can be packed into 14
lines and 113 words is a testament both
to yates and the continuing importance
of poetry.
All that's left is to pull one string
and see what sublime network of meanings
lights up.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
I had so much fun putting this video
together.
I love this poem.
I said in the last video that I'm doing
the nerd full time now and,
and this is the kind of quality of
content that I can make with this time
and this effort and it's all possible
because you guys have been pledging to
the channel on Patrion and I want to
continue to ask to donate a little bit
of your money to this channel because
there is so much more that I want to do
and I'm so excited for this stuff that's
coming up.
So as little as a dollar,
you can click right here on the screen
right now.
Everything helps.
Thank you again so much.
Um,
if you want to check out another video,
you can see my analysis of in the mood
for love,
which I did a couple of weeks ago.
Great movie.
I want to expand the series into a lot
of different art forms and mediums.
Comics a,
even maybe music,
TV,
lots of cool stuff.
I think there's just a lot of
opportunity for really awesome stuff and
then some stuff that isn't understanding
art.
It's coming up too,
so thank you again and I will see you
next time.